let's bring in someone else who knows a
lot about the white house kaylee
mackinnaney co-host of outnumbered and
former white house press secretary kaley
good morning thanks so much for being
here good morning
good morning pete and great job on that
number by the way it's fantastic to see
you there
uh so what's your reaction to jen saki
spending more time at the podium sort of
attempting to massage the word crisis
and what it's really about
than actually addressing it yeah
it's breathtaking i went and watched the
first 25 minutes of the briefing this
morning
and she used the word crisis but not in
relation to the border she said we have
a climate crisis
on our hands so we've got a climate
crisis we don't have a border crisis
when by the way what is happening with
these children on the border is
atrocious the conditions
the facilities it was a human rights
violation according to kamala harris
during the trump administration but now
it's just
they turn to turn a complete blind eye
to these children
uh it is an unmitigated crisis at the
southern border
fueled by a crisis in central america
and she wants to play nomenclature games
it's incredible
we saw last night on hannity show he
interviewed the president
first on camera interview since he left
the white house
i thought the strongest part kaylee of
that interview was
when he was talking about the border
because he said all biden had to do
was nothing leave it the way it was
listen to this
people are coming in by the tens of
thousands they're walking in
they we had all he had to do is leave it
alone if he left it alone
we were setting record positive numbers
and people would have to come in legally
and you know the other thing that people
don't talk about human trafficking and
drugs
that's double tripled and quadrupled
coming in because that's pouring in
right now drugs are pouring and we had
it so tight
we were doing so well all he had to do
was leave it alone and then he went on
to say the remain in mexico policy so
that was not easy to get we had to go
through the courts as a
system to get it and then biden comes in
day one and ends all of this
your reaction that's right president
yeah president trump got it right
i mean you can't argue with results you
can't argue with the 78
decrease in illegal border crossings you
can't argue with that and
he used common sense as he mentioned in
the interview yesterday
the wall worked i went with him i saw
the wall first hand
it worked these agreements with golden
triangle countries in mexico
they worked and biden destroyed and
dismantled the entire system
but you see these little tacit
admissions along the way that i think
even he recognizes those policies work
because mayorkis
reportedly has told people within dhs we
might close some of the gaps
in the wall they went back to mexico and
got troops on the border which is
exactly what president trump did so you
see these little tacit admissions that
they're realizing
in fact what he did was common sense i
mean look the the the president biden
gets dissed
all the time he got this by the
president of ecuador they were asked hey
could you see the
onboard president biden's envoy he said
no because you wouldn't see me when i
came to washington
so i'm not going to see you really so as
we get all these ecuadorians streaming
towards our border
the president said it's not my problem
because they have pride too
and they were disrespected early on by
this administration
yeah that's exactly right and then you
have the president of mexico calling him
the migrant president and placing the
blame for this illegal flow directly at
his feet
and in the northern triangle countries
you have one president there
saying hey you know smugglers are using
your language joe biden uh to get people
to come to this country so when you have
two world leaders and you mention
ecuador so three
calling you out something is going wrong
here
uh but he's too prideful i think to ever
backpedal although they did friday even
though jensocki won't admit it kaylee i
should have said el salvador my bad
all right i don't want to get ecuador
involved no problem all right
caleb real quick as well you mentioned
language
and the bite administration says they
want a more humane policy so their ice
and the border patrol are now saying you
can't use they put out a mandate
you cannot use illegal alien you cannot
say alien anymore it's all
undocumented uh migrant unaccompanied
children
non-citizens what does it mean when
they're changing the official words
and does it make it more humane no it
doesn't they're they're focused on a
word
uh when there are children who are being
placed uh with parents that may not even
be their actual parents because
apparently they've lightened up the
vetting procedures with placing these
unaccompanied minors
they're being they're trafficked human
trafficked abused on the journey here
and they're focused on a word
it's why people like dem senior democrat
lawmaker
henry cuellar a democrat has said i'll
stick with the original term which by
the way is in the statute until you
change the statute i'm going to use the
word
because henry cuellar is a democrat who
understands the reality of what's going
on
because he's there in the border in the
border area where even kamala harris and
joe
biden will not take a moment to even
visit
all right well kaylee thank you so much
for being on with us the president was
also asked about the jnj and he said
that is so stupid what they did all
right we'll look for you on outnumbered
congratulations again
and with pete giving you that compliment
he's going to want to be asked to come
on the show that's why he was doing it
and that's going to make brian very
jealous
he's welcome anytime pete so are you
brian